in this video we'll explain how to defer
a subscription renewal date for a user
this is often used as a customer service
tool in case the user experiences issues
with your service
for example if the user contacts you to
ask for help during a known service
outage you can respond by deferring
their subscription renewal using the
Google Play Developer API you can
advance the next billing date for a
subscriber the user continues to be
subscribed to the content and has full
access to it but is not charged during
the deferral period the subscription
renewal date will be updated to reflect
the new billing date that was passed to
the API you can advance the renewal date
by as little as one day or as long as
one year per API call once this is done
you may want to notify the user of this
change to their filling either in the
app or through email to learn more visit
the link on screen or check out our
other videos